the one idea that undergirds everything
is what we call frequency now frequency
this is a word you've met before you've
done some statistics back in years 9 and
10 even in your son's name frequency as
the name suggests is about how
frequently does something occur how
frequently does something occur so
you've gone and you've got your sample
you've asked them all of your survey
questions and then when you have a look
at their answers you want to kind of get
some patterns out of it so here's my
formal description for what frequency is
it's how many times does you know any
piece of data like how many people in
this room are girls how many people are
boys how many times that piece of data
occur so that's what we mean by
frequency how frequently is this
happening in the target population or in
the sample or whatever we're looking at
okay now it's really important just like
before when we're looking at tools like
which which kind of sample should we use
which of these concepts and I'm gonna
explain a few more kinds of frequency in
a second which of these concepts you use
and you apply to a situation really
depends on what are you using it for
like what are you trying to get out of
this data what one will be useful for
okay so frequency as an overarching idea
is all about identifying patterns and
trends so for instance I might be
interested in
well if we had a look at public schools
versus private schools is there a
disparity between the number of boys and
girls taking taking mathematics for
instance that would be an interesting
question for me and to work out what
kind of pattern or trend is there or
maybe a trend over time I don't know how
frequently the boys and girls are doing
that in such and such an such a school
okay so that's what frequencies now then
underneath these three rows that are
remaining we've got three different
kinds of frequency which kind of just
tease out this idea a little more okay
so the first one is what we call
relative frequency based on the name
I wonder how many of you could give me a
suggestion as to what you think it means
relative frequency what are you gonna go
very good so that relative word right
means I'm not just interested in okay in
a school you know I could say 200 girls
do you mathematics I could say that okay
now is that a lot or is it a little and
the answer is I don't know because I
need to know that in relation to like
the number of boys in relation to the
whole school population if the school's
only two into people then that's amazing
and also somewhat strange okay if the
school's two thousand will that mean
something very different doesn't it okay
so here's my proper formal definition
for relative frequency it's about like
frequency as a fraction or because you
can represent a fraction as a percentage
you could do a percentage as well
it's the frequency as a fraction or
percentage of the total population so
let's compare it to everyone in this
group so again the important question is
well where is this going when is it
useful and the thing I just alluded to
is a great example so if I'm comparing
different groups and the population
sizes of those groups are very very
different right
I guess maybe we could say for example
200 girls do maths this depends entirely
on the size of the turtle population so
rather than saying 200 girls to do maths
it might be much more meaningful to me
to say 50% of girls do maths or 50% of
the school rather it does maths or a
hundred percent of the school doesn't
ask all those kinds of things are giving
me much more meaning than just that wall
number okay so relative frequency now
this middle road when the data is I'm
going to leave this blank for a second
I'm going to explain the two kinds of
frequency that belong down here and then
at the end I'm gonna ask you if you can
fill in for me there are lots of
different types of data that you know
about do you remember this diagram this
one that looks like this okay so you
know about a whole bunch of different
kinds of data I want you to think as I
describe these next two and tell me
which of these you think they apply to
you okay so we looked at relative
frequency the next kind is called
cumulative frequency now when I
introduced this diner in statistics
topic I actually talked about cumulative
frequency as an example of like a
misleading graph
I do I do
so obviously the challenge here is
working how do i articulate I get the
idea
but what words am I going to use here my
words okay what you're thinking out
again is frequency but what you want is
the total frequency and you're sort of
keeping up with things as the quantities
that you're looking at are growing and
growing and growing so the way that we
would say this is the total frequency up
to and including now I'm going to give
you a arm a new phrase here up to an
including each data point so a data
point is like a specific instance in our
graph such as okay let's record
temperatures over the course of the year
okay a data point might be okay 30
degrees 30 degrees that's an interesting
kind of number can you tell me all of
the days how many days had temperatures
up to and including 30 degrees so you'd
add up the 30 degree days and the 29
degree days and 28 and so on okay
now figure out this one when is this
going to be useful why would you use
because I show you when you shouldn't
use cumulative frequency when it's
actually misleading but when we would
actually be useful to work this out
any thoughts when might be an actual
situation
okay so if you want to make a prediction
if you want again we talked earlier on
about patterns and trends so if you're
trying to make a forecast for the future
working out how this thing is working at
a community frequency graph might be
much more useful let me give you a
particular example
I'll phrase it for you and then I'll
give you the example so if what I want
to do is show progress for example over
the course of a year or something like
that if I've got particularly meaningful
data points that go together I can show
progress or I can group together those
data points now unfortunately this word
here meaningful is very very vague and
it kind of has to be because it could
mean a whole bunch of different things
so let me give you an example you might
want to say okay well what's the total
rainfall for this year how many
millimeters of rain have we gotten okay
and it would just make sense to say okay
well let's just look at each day and
just add up the millimeters and you're
gonna get a number by the end of the
year and that'll tell you has this been
a really rainy year or not so much
okay that's showing progress meaningful
data points could be all kinds of things
tell me all of the people in this class
who are able to you know score a 200
above on a game of bowling temping boy
something like that
right well which is a pretty decent
score right well you got us count up all
the people it's got two hundred and
$1.99 and 198 etc it's very difficult to
describe bowling scores and temperatures
or rainfall all in the same way so
that's why I just say meaningful okay
one last kind of frequency one last kind
which is what we call groups or class
frequency
now just because we're looking at this
table right now I'm just gonna describe
it for you but I'm going to give you
examples later on in this double period
because it's it's sort of its own idea
but it's related that's why I'm showing
it to you the idea is that what we want
to do is take a whole bunch of scores
individual scores and condense them
condense all those individual scores in
do well just like the just like the name
suggests put them together in groups
often those drips are called classes so
that's why it's got these two different
names okay so if you can condense those
individual scores into groups or
clusters or hey all of you people who
are between a hundred and fifty
centimeters and 160 centimeters tall or
all of the people who have scored
between 80 and 90 we call them band
fives
okay condensing those individual scores
into clusters what it helps you see is
larger patterns become more obvious
so I wonder if you could put up your
hand if you've heard the phrase don't
lose the forest for the trees who's
heard that phrase I'm actually
interested anyone find really one too
this is Penhall now we're having a bet I
said about a quarter
she said eight we're both wrong those
days the forest for the trees means
don't get so caught up in little bit all
my new details that you miss the fact
that there's this huge structure here
which you just kind of need to zoom out
a little bit and see okay there's this
massive structure that I need to
understand okay